de suite un obnl et il est rédacteur en
chef de la revue parlementaire
bonjour la merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors 10e samedi de
mobilisation ça veut dire quoi que le
mouvement ne s'essouffle pas
c'est un mouvement qui perdure mais qui
n'a pas exactement le même volume de
mobilisation qu'il ya encore quelques
semaines pour plusieurs raisons à mon
sens il ya certainement un phénomène
d'accoutumance d'une grande partie de
l'opinion publique quant aux mesures
sanitaires
le fait que vrai sens moment la pression
aujourd'hui épidémie que ce soit
peut-être aussi un peu moins forte
qu'elle ne l'était au mois d'août
dernier au début septembre et troisième
point on approche quand même
progressivement du terme aux yeux de la
loi
du maintien un fan venue de dépassement
on y passe sanitaire si je puis dire au
15 novembre le vrai sujet c'est
aujourd'hui de savoir si en fonction de
la situation épidémique le 15 novembre
l'échiné l'état d'urgence qui est liée
notamment à cet outil du bassin
sanitaire
sera derrière nous en tout cas on semble
aller dans ce sens c'est parce qu'on a
50 millions de crimes au vaccin depuis
hier fois on a des indicateurs
épidémique qui finalement ne sont pas si
mauvais que ça ça veut dire quoi que la
politique sanitaire peut-être avait être
assouplie dans les prochains jours
lens il trie on a des messages qui sont
assez contradictoires
parce que souvenez vous il y a quelques
semaines le ministre de la santé olivier
verrons avait envisagé la prorogation du
pass sanitaires depuis le début de
semaine on l'a plutôt des signaux qui
naissent réentendre que on irait vers un
assouplissement des contraintes
sanitaires mais comme depuis le début de
cette épidémie si l'allemand la
situation est extrêmement évolutive et
aujourd'hui à ce stade est extrêmement
difficile de pouvoir faire des
pronostics qui nous permettrait de dire
si oui ou non nous allons vers une
sortie en tout cas de cet état d'urgence
et notamment encore une fois vers la fin
du pass invités mais la question
fondamentale je crois qu'ils se posera à
terme en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation épidémique c'est aussi la
robustesse de la couverture vaccinale la
question qui aujourd'hui une question
qui n'est pas véritablement abordé mais
qui quand même et dans beaucoup de têtes
c'est de savoir si finalement les
mesures vaccinale qui ont été prises et
si le pastel caire qui notamment a
permis en tout cas fait en sorte que
nombre de français elle se faire
vacciner est ce que cette couverture
vaccinale sera suffisante par exemple
face à l'éventuelle surgissement de
nouveaux variants alors on disait en 10e
samedi de manifestation les français
sont en colère à ce que le gouvernement
l'état justement a entendu cette colère
est ce que le message finalement est
passé
écoutez
c'est très compliqué parce que enfin
quand on se rend compte qu'au début du
mouvement manifestement la communication
de l'exécutif était une communication
qui était pour le moins très ferme voire
parfois considéré qu'on provocatrice par
les gens et les personnes qui allaient
tous les samedis manifesté depuis force
est de constater que
l'exécutif est dans une situation plutôt
j'allais dire d'attentes par rapport à
ce mouvement
pensant vaisseau moment que le mouvement
va naturellement
s'essouffler
c'est un peu le cas quand même parce que
il est clair que encore une fois les
mobilisations sont plus au cas à ce
stade aussi importante qu'elle ne
l'était mais le risque c'est que
quand nous sommes dans un pays facture
et qu'il existe de multiples sources de
colère qui dépassent parfois le cadre
sanitaire c'est que ce mouvement puisse
rebondir à tout moment en agrégeant
d'autres colère qui sont aujourd'hui
très présente dans la société française
arnaud à benedetti merci à vous d'avoir
été envoyés sur rt france je rappelle
que vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la
revue parlementaire merci